اذا ما هي ازمه سقف الديون تم وضع سقف
الدين في عام
1917 لتمويل الحرب العالميه الاولى من
خلال تجميع السندات المختلفه في عام
1939 مع اقتراب الحرب العالميه الثانيه
انشا الكونجرس اول سقف اجمالي للديون وتم
رفع السقف ثمان وسبعين مره منذ عام
1960 بما في ذلك 20 مره منذ عام 2001 عاده
ما يرفع الكومبريس او يعلق سقف الدين قبل
الوصول اليه وعاده يقوم الحزب الذي خرج من
السلطه بالقاء اللوم على الطرف الاخر في
تبديره عام 2021 تم رفع حد السقف ليصل الى
31 تريليون دولار وهو ما يعني انه لا يجب
ان يزيد اجمالي قروض الحكومه الامريكيه عن
هذا الحد في حال بلوغ سقف الدين الحد
الاقصى فان ذلك يعني ان الحكومه
الفيدراليه لن تستطيع الحصول على قروض
جديده وهو ما يجعلها تتخلف عن تنفيذ
التزاماتها التي تتضمن سداد الديون
السابقه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات